o psol tem 21 hoje vou ensinar como
fazer uma bazuca usando um tubo e isto
foi usado em laca preta volta mas se
vocês não tiverem despolitiza pvc ou
então podem fazer um voz próprio tubo
que é só pegar um pedaço grande plano e
vão irlando quem vive fazendo isso por
cola pra ficar tudo existentes uma vez
que você manter o tubo é só vocês
vetorial e fazerem esta arma quando
chegarem para tratar tudo foi
inconsistente tomar algumas precauções
primário usar óculos de proteção em
descarregar a arma quem carrega um ar
muito vocês vão ver um tutorial e depois
tem por missão descaso e vou usar
bolinhas de papel e como é que vocês vão
colocar não vamos colocar assim eu caí
porque o fio pode arrebentar e disparar
contra vossa cara então você não fosse
formulado com base nos fez mal a ninguém
já a bolinha ir e pronto a usar e claro
você deve usar escola responsabilidade
porque tem alguma força são elásticos
forem de qualidade é e então vamos aos
testes pois o tutorial passo a passo
o confronto só chegamos o filho esperto
encostados vocês quiserem ajudar o canal
é só deixar um vai e se inscrevam para
acompanhar os próximos coisas que eu vou
fazendo casas onde o escrete é isso
então cardeal